president trump and i was there i i was
literally negotiating between the white
house and congress uh
the president had me here and then i
would go across the street and speak to
speaker pelosi speaker pelosi would tell
me to go back to the white house
so i was negotiating between the white
house and congress on this there was a
great deal president trump even
surprised me
with the number of dreamers he increased
it times two
he went from 800 000 to 1.6 million
dreamers
pastor sam we're gonna give dreamers a
pathway to citizenship
as long as i get my wall and protect the
border and stop all illegal immigration
and i went back to the speaker we
negotiated something and then chuck
schumer came along and said
we're not going to give president trump
a win that do your due diligence on this
it's been extensively covered
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is
the president of the national christian
leadership conference
as well as the author of be light
reverend samuel rodriguez welcome to the
reuben report
thank you for having me i'm glad to have
you because you know there's obviously a
lot going on
in your world not only is uh just past
easter and the passover season uh but
obviously there's a ton
going on on the immigration front and
many of the things that i've been seeing
you talk about uh mostly on fox lately
are a lot of things that i talk about on
this show and
you made some sense on cable news that's
a pretty rare thing these days so
so i thought i could have you on for the
people that that don't know you can give
me a little bit about your your back
story first and then we'll move into
the current days yeah i'm a kid from
bethlehem pennsylvania
hence bethlehem i have a messianic
complex
my dad was a mack truck worker uh my mom
was a homemaker i graduated from lehigh
university
i was raised in an evangelical home uh
my parents are not preachers
uh i'm a faith and science guy uh
ronald reagan inspired the living
daylights out of me
um and just prompted this commitment to
changing america and the world
with a value system that's
judeo-christian based
but this radical idea of god over man
and man over government
and so that's what we do my commitment
is to reconcile billy graham's message
of dr king's march i call it the lamb's
agenda it's doable
so you said a faith and science guy i
know my more skeptical
audience members their antennas just
went off what does a faith and science
guy mean
yeah i'm an evangelical trekkie so i'm a
faithful science guy i believe that that
science is the wonderful horizontal
expression
of the reality of a living god uh
you know i i i follow everything from
quantum physics my my encounter with god
at the highest level
took place in my undergraduate studies
at penn state university in a quantum
physics course
uh so i did not come through the normal
uh
you know watching a television christian
broadcast can you explain that a little
further
that that's pretty interesting yeah math
and science
it blew me away the newtonian laws uh
leap cig
the the ever-increasing reality of a
universe that continues to expand
the the beauty of the big bang uh the
intricacies
of the minerals that are out there in
the universe likewise on this planet
likewise
in your bloodstream and my bloodstream
the mathematical probability of that
happening by
chance it requires you to have more
faith
not to believe in a in a designer
and i'm sorry i don't have that crazy
cuckoo for coco puff faith
it does require you to have more faith
to believe this happened by chance
and just the math and the science all
adds up
um i'm a student of a guy named francis
collins
who oversees the the national health
institute right now
and he has been for a number of
presidents for obama and trump
um so again he discovered to a great
degree
unpacked unpacked better yet the human
genome
and he is a believer so again i don't
create a dichotomy between faith and
science
i think it's beautiful it's one
meta-narrative stream
that speaks to uh to a wonderful
architect a designer a god do you think
that one of our biggest problems
discussing this is that too many people
do
oh it's it's just either or you're
either a believer
in god or you're a believer in science
these things can't touch
right i i that is a false dichotomy uh
because i
am a believer in god i'm a believer in
science uh
absolutely and because i'm a believer in
science i'm a believer in god
it's one continual stream it i think we
suffer from
cognitive dissonance like we're lacking
the sort of cerebral bandwidth and wi-fi
to really look at the big picture and if
we do adhere to succumb to or acquiesce
to the idea
of a designer then everything else
becomes
a little bit more uh palpable
and if that designer has a plan for in
for the universe does he have a design
and a plan for individual lives
and then it becomes more personal and
that's where i come in as a pastor and a
preacher and dissect that and bring it
about every single time so
speaking of your your job as a preacher
in this last year where we've had
lockdowns and pandemic and people out of
work and all of that stuff
have you noticed people looking for
something different spiritually
or from the church you know what
you would assume that a global pandemic
would catapult the the quant the the
measurement or the metric of agnosticism
just from a logical continuum if there's
a god how can he permit you know that
that the
it is the quintessential query right if
there's a god why does he permit evil to
happen that sort of thing
so a global pandemic you know over 500
000 deaths in america yeah
there can be well guess what every
single survey
including one i just read four days ago
the level of spiritual hunger has
increased exponentially now i'm not
saying it's for
organized religion i'm saying the level
of spiritual hunger
has increased exponentially so people
are hungry for a relationship with god
for greater spirituality spiritual
awakening awareness
so that's where we commit and that's why
i fought back
when governor newsom in california in
our collective state you and i are part
of you are in california you are in
california yeah
i didn't want to i didn't want to help
you you outed yourself
you i doubt it myself when when he
deemed
casinos and liquor stores essential but
churches and synagogues
not are you kidding me you know guess
who gets the call for
for health issues yeah we do uh when
young men and women right now greater
numbers in california as it pertains to
god it's unfortunate the suicide rate
drug abuse
alcoholism depression we've never seen
these numbers guess who they call
they don't call a guy in the liquor
store they don't so jack daniels
should not trump moses and jesus i just
it's just
illogical but that's what governor
newsom did while he was
at you know having dinner at the french
laundry and that's that's another story
for him
my audience knows that story well so
fear not we don't have to dive too much
into that but you mentioned sort of
the role of god of government of of man
all of those things
you've been able to piece something
together that that's pretty holistic
that sort of forms your
your political views as well it sounds
like
god over man man over government that's
the pecking order that's american
exceptionalism
that right there god over man man over
government
and when government grows it's going to
sound a little bit naive
or you know here it is government grows
it
it pushes man and god out of the way
this uber dependency on government
and this unbelievable obsession with
uncle sam
it's not part of the ethos of our
founding fathers it isn't it's
anti-american
it really this obsession with god
with government instead of instead of
our god-ordained giftings and abilities
uncle sam is an uncle he'll never be our
heavenly father
he's just an uncle so we respect the
uncle
unless the uncle gets drunk in that
family party
you know we respect the uncle but we
worship god
and right now and even the recent
proposals from the biden administration
from the not just the 1.9 trillion but
now the infrastructure bill
all of this this unbridled growth
of government ladies and gentlemen uh
government is becoming our god i'm
pretty
i'm pretty sure and we are and we and we
are what we tolerate so we're tolerating
yeah and i'm pretty sure the
uncle is drunk at the moment he's drunk
and he's spending a lot of other
people's money
do you view that obsession with
government
as just the the next step down the road
because of the god-shaped hole that if
basically you don't you are not a
believer
you got to believe in something and then
government just kind of fills it in
do we find do we have measurable
elements that we can dissect
historically so it's not hype and it's
not rhetorical exuberance can we measure
it
let's measure it in it right after world
war ii 77 76
of all americans attended a church or a
synagogue 76
that number according to last week's
survey from gallup is now 48
for the first time what does this mean
let's not forget what we were fighting
back in the 40s and 50s communism
this idea of unbridled government being
gone
stemming out of the ussr through china
all around the world
here it is it's 2021 government is
growing
god god and meeting the belief in god
is decreasing in america it's directly
parallel
it's directly proportional the more we
get away from god
the more government plays a role in our
lives i'm telling you it's replacement
theology
it's not like we're doing away with god
and then there's this great vacuum
there is spiritual hunger and there's
hunger this is going to seem a little
bit
difficult for me as a with my worldview
this issue of dependency so who do we
depend on
god or government and we are replacing
god
and his abilities giftings his his
wisdom
uh his preordained institutions of
family
and so forth we're replacing that with
government
it's big government big government is
anti-christian
it's anti-jewish it's
anti-judeo-christian value system it's
anti-american
and right now we are drinking the
kool-aid all
under the guise of a pandemic it's so
how do you blend that
with what i know you believe which is a
separation between church and state
what what should the role of government
uh of religion
in state be then is is it just up to the
individuals should the state be
fostering it somehow
and i know you've done this before and
just let me for the audience say
that separation of church and state that
jeffersonian letter
to that amazing church i we we have
totally
taken this on the ideological left they
have taken that out of context
and it's church should not have a place
in the public sphere
quite the contrary please do your
diligence on this
jefferson is writing saying government
should never have the right we have to
separate
government from thinking it even has the
notion or the right for a moment
to quelch silence limit to somehow
hinder obstruct
the free expression of worship and faith
so jefferson is saying
government better not touch faith and
religion
not the other way around not that
religion and faith shouldn't touch the
public's fear
we have a place in the public sphere
people of faith even that beautiful
faithful expression
george washington referenced it at the
latter portion of his presidency
about this commitment to faith is the
backbone
of this new american experience abraham
lincoln reiterated that david
dwight david eisenhower again ronald
reagan of course elevated it
to the stratosphere yes so i do believe
that we
and right now that's not happening right
now government is telling me
that i have to change my theology in
order to accommodate
cultural shifts that are just not
specific
i mean are you kidding me there are laws
as we speak
including the equality act which is not
equal
other attempts to diminish my ability to
speak what i believe is truth eternal
truth
truth that stems from from a natural law
from a a moral compass that's way beyond
your generation and my generation
that is the backbone of civilization and
somehow i'm supposed to sacrifice truth
on the altar of political or cultural
or generational expediency so yes there
is a separation but to protect
the free expression of faith how much of
your time as a pastor is devoted to that
i mean basically inoculating your
congregation
from the whims of the day because i hear
i hear from all sorts of faith leaders
that social justice is creeping into
their synagogues creeping into their
churches
etc and again even the notion of social
justice i believe in biblical justice
which uh
biblical justice which is micah 6 8 do
justice love mercy walk humbly it's
psalm 89 14.
it's luke chapter 4. so i believe in
biblical justice
and biblical justice is an extension of
righteousness
so when all these things happen last
year i looked at my church here's an
interesting thing
my church is 40 white which is code word
for caucasian
percent black which is african american
and twenty percent latino and asian
i am blessed to to oversee a very
beautifully multi-ethnically diverse
congregation
when everything happened last year i
i've approached the podium and i said
ladies and gentlemen
we will biblically speaking address
any and all vestiges of bigotry and
we'll do it with the authority of
scripture but we won't do it in the name
of any movement
that runs calendar to the values that
you and i hold near and dear
we will not do it in any movement's name
as a christian we're going to do it in
the name of jesus
so again we can separate but when
churches begin to drink the kool-aid
of social justice as interpreted by the
ideological left
it's not just troublesome it's the
beginning of the slippery slope i
wouldn't even argue
the biggest problem in america right now
is not even moral relativism
or cultural decadence or even big
government the problem in america is a
lukewarm church it's a church in a
religious community
that's drinking the kool-aid and we're
bowie
we're bowing at the altar of race
somehow race just became god
do you realize that there are pastors
that speak more about race than they do
about jesus or moses
or abraham so race and sexuality
just became idols and we are worshiping
on the altar
of the gods created by created by
individuals
who are inclined to a morally
relativistic worldview who
who embrace anarchy and chaos
and we're bowing to this and that's the
problem in america so what do you think
the flaw was
in the in the leadership of either the
churches or
the temples or probably in the mosques
as well
that allowed the people that are
supposed to be the leaders like you the
pastors
to allow it in you you think i was it
was it the fault of the pastors for
allowing it
i mean if enough people if enough people
are coming to them with something
it's leadership it always does it always
falls on leadership
it always falls on leadership and and we
are all and i'm part of the collective
leadership motif here we're all to blame
we are uh we need to repent it's a
second chronicles 7 14 moment
it we need to repent we really do we've
permitted this and by the way it's this
like like like like like like like like
we are more committed to likes and
followers
than we are to truth and when we're more
committed to likes and followers and we
are to truth
we begin to water down truth acquiesce
truth surrender truth
and then our children will reap the
consequences of our complacency
today's complacency is tomorrow's
captivity and right now we are
complacent
and we're comfortable and it's a shame
because our children are watching and
they're going to pay the price
of secular totalitarianism of socialism
of communism of anti-science
there's no biology human physiology
doesn't matter
science doesn't matter we're they're
going to reap the consequences of
our activities in our generation yeah i
can now see that
my audience will get why i wanted to
have you on because you're hitting so
many of the topics that
that i talk about all the time i i want
to talk to you about immigration
uh in just a bit but what else did you
find in this past
year that people were coming to you
because i do sense what you hinted at
there about a spiritual awakening i've
been saying for a while you know
at a micro level i think an atheist or
an absolutely perfect secular view of
the world can work
meaning individual people can do that i
think it takes
a certain type of person but i think
it's possible but at the macro level it
just simply can't work it can't work and
even the atheists and agnostics
who i have some as friends when we have
these conversations these sort of
metaphysical and cosmic conversations of
the big picture
uh i call it the extension of the big
bang it's still happening
and they even allude to the fact many of
them even some of them that are pretty
prominent have referenced the fact
that precise for society to function we
need
a set of morals mores a value system
that has a viable religious spiritual
component to it
they don't negate that it's part of who
we are as human beings it's part of our
spiritual genome uh without a doubt
so yes i have seen in the past year not
only spiritual hunger
but i have seen likewise this
fear of what's next of
the immediate sacrifice of our ability
to express ourselves spiritually
as it pertains to faith and religion at
the drop of a dime
how we have surrendered so much and how
government
is so much more powerful than we ever
ever would have conceived or thought of
yeah
that sort of that fear is there are you
shocked
are you shocked how quickly everyone
just kind of put their hands up and said
okay i'm not going to go to church
anymore i'm not going to go to temple
anymore i'm not going to go to work
anymore et cetera et cetera
that it i am blown away intellectually
emotionally spiritually
we just surrendered everything i mean
everything and it wasn't even proof
meaning
it was theoretical back then right we
had no idea so you could argue because
we had no idea we had the right i don't
know if you had the right
i really don't and so here's what i
discovered
they that my constitution is only as
good and viable as long as we don't have
an emergency
so my god-given rights come to an
end when a virus or any other government
deemed emergency yeah whatever is there
so they're not yeah so they're not
they're not absolute
they're not eternal because government
can take away
scary times it's revealing it's exposing
some weaknesses
in the in the collective of what we call
the american experience
and the global human experience for that
matter yeah so i first off
i normally don't ask a guest to come
back in the middle of a show but i'd
love to have you come back when we do
some more panels on religion and i'll
get you
on with some other religious leaders
because i think we can unpack a lot of
that stuff but i want to shift to
immigration because that's sort of
how you got on my radar so there's
obviously a lot going on
at the southern border right now i'll
just sort of give you a vague question
here which is
how should we be thinking about what's
going on here because it's getting
very very difficult to even understand
what's remotely true meaning okay did
obama
start the cages and are the cages worse
because of trump and then they got
better and now
it's like everything feels like just
such a mess
so i can i can give you not anecdotally
what i can give you from being involved
since george w bush uh i worked at the
bush administration
matter as an advisor i worked with karl
rove directly
and i worked with obama for eight years
on this matter
and i worked for president trump on this
matter and other matters by the way
so here it is wow
this is chaotic on multiple levels let
me lay it out for you
we have the ability to solve this we can
solve this the immigration crisis
is just the outcome of political
expediencies
on both sides of the aisle george w bush
had a great proposal should have passed
didn't pass
a couple of people from the republican
side put a halt on that and that's a
shame
during the obama administration
president obama made health care a
priority
sacrificed immigration and that's a
shame
and he had two years by the way to do it
where he had control yeah he could have
done whatever he wanted
boom so this is the fault of again
you know healthcare trumps immigration
president trump and i was there i
i was literally negotiating between the
white house and congress uh
the president had me here and then i
would go across the street and speak to
speaker pelosi speaker pelosi would tell
me to go back to the white house
so i was negotiating between the white
house and congress on this there was a
great deal president trump even
surprised me
with the number of dreamers he increased
it times two
he went from 800 000 to 1.6 million
dreamers
pastor sam we're gonna give dreamers a
pathway to citizenship
as long as i get my wall and protect the
border and stop all illegal immigration
and i went back to the speaker we
negotiated something and then chuck
schumer came along and said
we're not going to give president trump
a win that do your due diligence on this
it's been extensively covered so what's
what do we do now right now in the
border we have a crisis
guess what the cages were built by
president obama's administration yeah
there it's just the fact they came to
fact they were from the obama
administration as a matter of fact
even the pictures that were used against
president trump that were from the obama
administration
so that's a lie that became not true
that was perceived to be truth by mass
media
currently right now they're in the same
places
that president biden and kamala harris
spoke against in every single debate
they are actually putting
young men and women boys and girls in
the same identical places i kid you not
the same identical facilities with the
same identical conditions
it actually seems far worse aren't
aren't they more packed now
it's way more packed than i should know
i've traveled to these centers i've been
there
i've interviewed i've interviewed custom
border patrol agents
many of them attend our churches so i
even did some sidebars i went hey guys
tell me the truth just as people of
faith please tell me the truth
off the record they went hey hey pastor
sam we're not like setting this up
to try to convince you of anything this
is the reality so i've been there
the reality is right now under the biden
administration there is a greater crisis
than ever during the trump
administration as it pertains to
children
coming in it is tragic i mean the
stories are
heartbreaking babies toddlers we're
talking about
toddlers it's a pastor and as a dad
it's heartbreaking to see the images and
this is because the biden administration
gave a
wink and a nod for people to come over
they did they can't
deny it they did and now we're reaping
the consequences
but there is a solution and it here it
is
here's a proposal number one we need to
secure our border
we're a sovereign nation open borders
doesn't work
open borders invites sex trafficking
the drug cartels they are smiling the
cartels are smiling right now
this idea this notion is so
anti-american and as a pastor committed
to ending human and sex trafficking
i repudiate what's currently taking
place at the border
we need to secure the border stop all
illegal immigration
we want people coming here legally not
illegally and we can't have it both ways
we can't
we can't permit more people coming here
illegally breaking the law
and then we're telling people they won't
they must wear masks which
is right so there's a segment of society
that has to adhere to the law
yet there's a group of individuals that
don't have to adhere to or obey the law
that lack of continuity subconsciously
creates
a construct which leads to behavior
that produces chaos and anarchy a lack
of coherency right
so we have to make up our minds let's
protect the border stop illegal
immigration and we can do it even
not just through a physical wall
infrared technology
satellite imaging come on we could read
the license plate from a car in
afghanistan from a satellite
we can stop thousands crossing over the
rio grande backpacks
so we have the technology to do it let's
do that let's stop all illegal
immigration
the second thing we must do is get the
dreamers on a pathway
to become citizens just the dreamers now
because i still believe the kids should
not pay for the sense of their parents
some of your audience would disagree
with that i just find it to be logical
if you were brought over when you were
three four five years old
i mean come on right and now you're and
now you're 20 years old are you kicking
these people out of the comments
and you grew up here you don't even
speak spanish you know you grew up in
our in our educational system
it's let's find a pathway as long as
you're not involved in various
activities you're not again you're not
involved in gangs
et cetera et cetera let's speak let's
let's have these individuals become
citizens but those their parents
that's where i differ where i'm even
maybe too conservative
for some of my friends on the right i
don't think that
the parents who came here illegally
should ever become citizens so
what do you do with it there's a there's
a price to pay we give them a green card
so this is what we do if you're not
living off government entitlement if
you're not living off welfare
and i know that you're you're probably
using false social security numbers that
is a crime you know you're going to have
to
recognize the fact that you broke the
law that you have been breaking the law
you should be paying some fines but
you've been we've been here for 20 25
years
working and some of these individuals
are some of the hardest working
individuals i know i live in california
so that's not true that's giving
speaking truth to power and they attend
our church some of the most beautiful
people on the planet they should have
come here legally by the way
all right did that ship sale yes but
there's a price to pay
we're gonna give you a green card stay
in america you no longer have to fear
being deported
but you're never going to become a
citizen there's a price to pay
how in the world can we compensate
people that came here illegally with
citizenship
for crying out loud when there are
people waiting in line
legally in nations attempting to come
into this country the right way
it's just wrong so my my proposal which
i gave to president trump
and i gave it to a number of senators
that are just of close friends
i said here's the proposal i call it a
just integration solution
and i think the vast majority of
americans would embrace this and matter
of fact i know because we did some
polling and they actually would
including
members of the freedom caucus the most
conservative individuals who say that
sounds fair
that sounds fair all right there's a lot
of different ways we could go here so
what do you think the wink
that you're talking about the the biden
administration wink what do you think it
really is all about so if they're
telling you because they're kind of like
don't come
maybe come in a few weeks you can kind
of come but what do you think they're
actually trying to accomplish with the
wink are they trying to get all these
people there and do they have any
intention of actually
doing what you said which is we've got
to secure a border and it's the right of
every cyber nation to do so
now i i don't think and i say there's a
great deal deference i don't think the
current administration has any viable
commitment it's not
i can't measure it if you can't measure
it and it's not legit
as it pertains to this outcome i don't
see any
any sort of evidence that this
administration is committed to
protecting the sovereignty of america
not it's it's there are many open border
operatives that come from the heart
ideological left
and right now unfortunately they seem to
have the ear of our president
and and it is unfortunate it is so i
think the objective
is there's twofold there are those and i
can't judge
everyone across the board i'm looking at
political outcomes
there is a group of individuals that
really
with a great heart would love to see
america you know emerge
as the the phrase on the statue of
liberty the the place that
of refuge and hope for people that are
broken around the world
but that's utopia we we can't open up
for the entire world
we just don't have the bandwidth we're
not the new jerusalem if you're an
evangelical or a christian
you know we're this is not heaven this
is not the new earth
whatever you want to call it in your
theological worldview we're not there
uh so we can't we have to protect our
borders
the second thing is and this seems a
little bit more complicit
but i know there's some conversation
with leadership on the
hard left there is an attempt to change
america with more voters there is and it
sounds oh that's that's that's just wild
sam no it isn't again some people are
doing it with good intentions
yet apollyonish a bit a bit of an utopic
sort of worldview
and then there are some that have a more
i would call it wicked
sort of imperative which is let's change
the demographical landscape to such a
degree
that we're going to secure power for
generations to come
that's wicked because you're dealing
with human lives
beautiful people created in the image of
god that are seeking a better day we
want them to do it legally
i believe immigrants are a blessing and
not a burden if they come here legally
but i believe it is wicked and morally
reprehensible to use human beings as
political pawns
so did you get any sense that
trump just could not or i guess this is
the sense you got trump just could not
get anything done because no matter what
he was going to offer that at the end
even if pelosi kind of nodded to it
schumer was going to blow it up or
i don't even have to blame schumer but
just that the machine was just going to
say we're not going to give the guy a
win sure he's going to double the amount
of dreamers
but we're not going to give him a win on
the wall and this is just how
bad politics is that deal was
was one of the best deals that i've seen
since working on this since 2006.
it really was and just and i met with po
potus with president trump on this um
and i met with general kelly secretary
nielsen back then
and i was blown away i'm going like what
just happened
like what and and his commitment
uh amazing and even when president trump
would speak to hispanic americans to
latino americans
he would repeat that uh you know and and
i'm going whoa
this is not part of the collective sort
of media exacerbated narrative
of a racist president it's not i mean
you know which is it right and what he
offered was a
great deal that should have and again
the democrats just said
no because we can't give him a win with
the latino community
and we can't give him a win on
immigration i mean that just destroys
our narrative
and it's a shame because again they're
playing politics with human lives yeah
so speaking of the latino community i
wonder either
within your congregation or just in your
in your life you know there's a lot of
people saying that
the latino community that has come here
legally
and thrived for now generations that
they're
actually more anti-illegal immigration
than the average white liberal because
they did it the right way and they're
sort of being bucketed in with this
whole thing
that that's actually that's not like
hype or or
a theoretical that's that's proven
through surveys time and time again
and and even recently in the past 48
hours
the latino community wants to stop the
crisis at the border and wants to stop
illegal immigration
yeah without a doubt the assumption that
hispanic americans and latinos
are this just you know part and parcel
group of
a left-wing ideological worldview
no quite the contrary i can tell you
firsthand and the numbers don't lie
so 36 of latinos supported an agenda of
what i call
life religious liberty biblical justice
limited government in the in the
2020 election and in florida that was
close to 50
which was the game change texas so and
by the way 44
of all latinos voted for george w bush
in 2004.
so the idea that latinos will probably
become the future of the conservative
movement in america
if i were a betting man which i'm not
yep
i would i would put some money on that
the future
conservative leaders will probably be
latino because we're committed to faith
family hard work and limited government
so when you hear aoc and others
elevating the notion of socialism
hispanics are going are you kidding we
have cousins in venezuela right who can
you who are literally starving i don't
mean like
i mean literally starving because of
socialism
in bolivia in nicaragua in cuba with
communism
and you're telling me that socialism is
the next for america
so when latinos see government growth we
get anxiety attacks it's
acid reflux yeah well i can tell you i
was just in miami and the cubans of
miami trust me these are the most
pro-america people you have
ever you can't even imagine a group of
people that would be more pro-america
actually
indeed that's why i do believe let me
tell you who's in more danger the
ideological
left is in more danger because of the
demographical shifts in america
again all we need to do is if we are
committed to
god will remain men over government to
limited government to personal
responsibility
to our judeo-christian value system as
it pertains to morality
to nurturing family structures that are
just
that are just flourishing uh et cetera
et cetera if we're committed to that
that we have to engage the latino
community at a different level
and all of us must have a greater
conversation and understand that dorothy
were not in kansas anymore
how do you blend your ability to lead a
congregation but to also be a public
figure to talk about politics but also
talk about religion
i'm sure when you're given a sermon
you're trying to be as careful
well i don't want to put words in your
mouth but i would imagine you you're as
careful as you can be
to not be overtly political and yet so
many people now because politics is in
everything
come to you for some sort of political
leadership which is and and because
you've also worked with
uh at least three administrations
correct i think that the legitimacy
of working with three administrations
and i did not vote for
for for all of these presidents i did
not i can't i'm a i am staunchly
pro-life and i'm not ashamed of that
so i made a commitment to god into my
family that i would never vote for a
candidate it's not pro-life i just
believe in the ethos of life and what it
means
um but with that being said it gives me
that sort of legitimacy number two i
just want to speak truth with love
so i never come out with with sort of
anger
on occasion righteous indignation
hopefully um
but but speak truth with love and love
people even when i disagree with them
and and respect them so i just don't
tolerate them it's gonna
it's gonna become very hippie-ish now
california hippie-ish
so i love people that i disagree with
because i'm a christian i'm called to
love
not just tolerate so i disagree with you
but i respect you and recognize that
you're created in god's image
so i love you even though i disagree
with you bitterly and that's the
sort of way that i look at things and
approach things from preachings to
sermons
to public platforms on the most critical
and divisive of issues
i think you slightly just answered this
but because it's the easter season
because we just passed easter
can you just talk a little bit about how
easter the message of easter
uh is is important right now yeah you
know
you know as a christian again that that
message to me is just powerful and
coming out of this covenant 19 pandemic
the fact that jesus came out of the tomb
enables us to come to the reality
that with that resurrection power with
romans 8 11 the apostle paul writing
said the same spirit
that resurrected jesus lives in you we
can come out of despair
we can come out of anxiety fear
confusion chaos we can come out of
brokenness
but we can come out of the most dire of
circumstances
jesus came out of the tomb you and i can
come out of the most precarious
negative of circumstances by faith
that's the resurrection message
that there is eternal life to the
vicarious atoning work of christ
and there's life even beyond this life
but when we're on this side of eternity
we can be light and live out that life
where
i just don't ask god for a blessing i
ask god to make me a blessing
where i ask god to make me the answer to
someone else's prayer
i really believe that through that
resurrection message we can change
the world do you ever have doubts
anymore
yeah absolutely and to say i don't
would lack integrity yes and
and this is going to sound awkward i
embrace him
because it reminds me of my humanity and
and it
prompts me to have a continual
conversation
with god uh with my thoughts
to prune to test my ideology
my belief system i think it's beautiful
and i don't think god is ever afraid of
our questions
ever i think we have a god who welcomes
queries and questions i love it i love
it i love it i just
absolutely love it hey adam and eve
genesis
god turns around and says after the fall
hey adam
where are you like he didn't know right
like he did it's just a question of find
yourself
do you know where you really are really
in life
with me with purpose where are you so i
love questions doubts
don't bother me i i welcome them as long
as
they don't put a lid on my faith
i'm curious did you track the rise of
jordan peterson at all
were you paying i am i i i'm full
disclosure i'm a fan oh okay all right
well then
that that's a perfect segue because you
know as you bring up adam and eve and we
can talk obviously about biblical
stories you know he did so much on these
biblical stories and what i saw that was
so fascinating when i was on tour with
him
was that people who were not religious
they were either they were either
atheist or agnostic or just sort of a
religious or hadn't really thought about
it much
suddenly they're hearing him talk about
these stories that they kind of know
through culture or maybe some religious
teaching or something
and and it was changing them and it was
just incredible for me to see night
after night
now these narratives of scripture are
are full of truth
and virtue and life lessons that are
eternal
eternal uh to to this very moment is
very our if we pass these teachings down
to from one generation to the other
there's hope for the next indeed what
else is on your mind
right now sort of as not only as a
preacher but as as a leader
as as someone involved in the political
world i mean what else are you thinking
about right now
i i am concerned i actually spoke to my
wife about this before we came
together for this interview last night i
i said honey i need to be careful
of i find myself on the fence dipping a
little bit
on drink not drinking the kool-aid of
despair but things are just going a hell
in a handbasket
legislatively um as it pertains to
values
and and rights that we have i'm
concerned about the next generation
i don't want to go into a pit so what's
in my mind is instead of focusing on the
darkness turning on the light
and how do we do that let's mobilize
people let's message and mobilize
for the purpose of not drinking the
kool-aid and tolerating this reality as
if we could do absolutely nothing to
build a firewall
i want to build a firewall of
righteousness and justice i have this
crazy world view that we can do this
we can push back um moral relativism
cultural decadence big government
telling me there is no such thing as
gender and truth and science and faith
and god
we can push back against anarchy and
chaos that's what's on my mind
a multi-generational multi-ethnic
movement
of righteousness and justice truth and
love that's what's on my mind
well with that in mind do you think we
can recall this gavin newsom guy or what
i sure hope so i sure don't know we need
to flip california because it's just
it's just crazy
this is secular totalitarianism it's
crazy it's nutty
are you shocked are you shocked that so
many i mean the thing that always gets
me with californians
especially i'm in la it's like they
always know something's wrong if you ask
someone
how's it going in l.a everyone's like oh
there's homeless people everywhere the
drugs the taxes are high
and then if you and then you're like all
right well you do realize we're just
voting for one party endlessly forever
and they can't seem to put that together
yep by the way that's pete wilson
god bless him uh that's you know he did
that i kid you not because
california listen folks uh dave knows
that sam knows it's california
you gotta engage the latino vote you
have to it's the demographic of reality
right and
way before this is not just now that's
just california
so when he came along and just alienated
flipped off the latino bow boat that was
the beginning of a downhill
slide and cycle that he gave california
to one
party and it's dangerous one party rule
however the level of frustration right
now
and angst it's up here so we have
moderate democrats and what i call
thinking democrats that don't drink the
ideological kool-aid but our centrist
and more moderate more common sense
the jfk that remnant that's still around
minority but still around that john f
kennedy sort of democrat
they're waking up and going like what is
this
so i think california could actually
change it's doable
just requires a lot of different
coalitions very unique coalitions
you know you've given me a lot of a lot
of hope here but i feel i should give
you
one last uh one last moment of hope
to go out on it's real simple
at the end of the day at the end of the
day love over overcomes hate
truth defeats the lie it may take a
cycle or two
but at the end of the day i still
believe that every single time light
stands next to darkness
light always wins so regardless of
whatever emerges
using the old testament as a context
here pharaoh
goliath nebuchadnezzar uh jezebel
god for whatever reason always appointed
men and women to rise up
and push back so for every pharaoh there
must be a moses and for every goliath
there must be a david
for every jezebel there must be an
elijah for every nebuchadnezzar there
must be a daniel
and in the new testament for every herod
there must be a jesus
let not your heart be troubled there's
always going to be light
and light will always overcome darkness
all right well
on that note i mean i'm trying to do
more of of these types of shows to give
people some things that aren't just in
that horizontal world that we have but
also in that vertical world we have so i
hope you'll come back
and uh and one of these days we'll meet
somewhere in socal when they let us out
of our houses
we'll do honored to be with you thank
you for having me sam it was a pleasure
thank you so much
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about
spirituality instead of non-stop yelling
check out our spirituality playlist and
if you want to watch full interviews on
a variety of topics check out our full
episode playlist they're all right over
here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell